router guards are used in angular to
prevent unauthorized users from
navigating anywhere they want in your
app at this point our app has a working
fire based authentication system but any
visitor can access routes intended only
for logged in users guards handled this
problem by implementing the can activate
interface which tells angular whether or
not to activate a certain route in this
example we will protect pages from
unauthenticated users and redirect them
to a sign-in page we use the CLI and
angular 4 to generate a default guard
guards use the injectable decorator
so they need to be registered as
provider just like any other service and
the app module our users are
authenticating via firebase and angular
fire to package in the service we are
subscribing the firebase off-state than
using a getter to see if the auth object
is null check out the OAuth tutorial for
more details on this code router guards
always return a boolean type or boolean
observable the logic here is simple if
the firebase off state is defined we
activate the route otherwise we return
false and navigate the user to the login
page
now that the guard is complete we just
need to apply it to specific routes in
the routing module that's it for router
guards I'll see you next time
[Music]
Oh
[Music]